I'm so happy you're here. I'm
happy. This is your first
tonight show appearance. This
is my first time you guys.
I'm happy that you're here. Uh
what a great time because this
is your sixth season. You have
a lot going on right now.
You're also on shrinking on
Apple TV Plus. Jason Siegel and
Harrison Ford. Yes, we have
some fans. Uh I have questions
about you though because before
comedy was a part of your life.
You are a hairdresser. Yeah.
Yeah. I did hair. Whoo. Uh
that's cool. Yeah. And what did
you did everyone know that all
your clients know that you were
funny and they were like, oh
you're going to be on Saturday Night Live
and you're going to be. Not at
all. I I kept the comedy thing
very secret. So, when I told
them like, yeah, I I'm leaving
the salon to pursue comedy.
They all said, are you funny?
Wow. I just said time will
tell. Wow. Are you funny? All
you do is talk to them the
whole time. Are you a good
hairdresser? I am a good
hairdresser. I did all my
friends, all my family.
Actually, my last hold out
client was my dad. Oh, I know
because he had a very specific
haircut that he's been getting
for decades. Um I don't know if
any of the guys are familiar
here. It's called the Mummy
Cut. Okay, so no do you have
you ever gotten the mummy cut
no I have no idea what that is
okay the mommy cut is Brendon
Frazier and the mummy's hair
are you guys were calling oh
yeah now I now I know what
you're talking about this is oh
yeah okay right it's like a
pretty cool hair no I did and
yeah he's a stud yeah okay so
my dad's been getting that cut
for 25 years oh and it was a
big night in our family when
Brendon Frasier won the Oscar
because the next morning I got
a text from my dad that said
Brendan for the Oscar.and. I
chose the haircut years ago.
And so I think you yes. He
thinks he's responsible for
Brendan Fraser getting it
Oscar. Yes but I didn't hear
Brendan Frazier thank Rick
Gardner. So tonight maybe we
thank Rick Gardner. Yeah thank
you Rick. Thank you. For
Brendan's career. Oh, here is
your dad. Oh, interesting.
Here's your dad with the mommy
cut. Mommy cut, right? Yeah,
not too bad. The swoops? Yeah,
he looks good actually. Yeah.
Yes. Wow. Fantastic. He's a
stunt. The white shirt? Rick,
good job. Congratulations. It's
a mommy cap. Uh are are you are
you from Kansas City, right?
This is this, I know you're a
big Kansas City Kansas, you
love it. I love it. You do. I
love it. Yeah, I think good
nights. I see you when you wave
goodnight. Sometimes you're
wearing the jersey or somebody
that. Head to toe cheese
overalls. Yeah. All all Kansas
City. Um even when I go home
now. I love to go back to
Kansas City and actually my
dad, Rick Gardner. Um we have a
tradition. I know him. You know
Rick the mommy cap. Yeah he's
the one that got Brendan Fraser
the Oscar. Yeah we all know. My
dad. Pretty famous. Um so, he
has this tradition where he
likes to take me to like the
greasiest diner or find like
the most loaded burger. Yeah.
Stuff and so this last time I
went home, he was like, I found
this ground beef taco where the
cheese is the powder from Kraft
Macaroni said a place called in
a tub and their sign is a
bathtub. Um we gotta go try it
and I go, that sounds
disgusting. Yes, let's go.
Yeah, of course. Yes. It does
to me that sounds fantastic.
Yes. So. Cheese is the powder
from Craft Macaroni cheese. For
the kids, you know. Oh, for the
kids. Yeah, of course. I sound
so like something I would love
to eat yeah the kids get in
line yeah exactly yeah so we
get in the car to go and it
just so happens that I decided
to wear like the most expensive
pristine pair of white pants we
go to in a tub we're eating
eating the ground beef taco
with the powdered cheese it's
delicious he was right yes I
get like just the tiniest speck
of that powdered cheese on my
pants and I knew if I took a
nap it would spread it. Can't
touch it. Yeah. So, I was like,
I'm going to have to blow this
off but I was like at a weird
angle to like blow on myself
and my husband who was also
enjoying a ground beef taco. I
turned to him and I was like,
hey babe, would you just blow
that cheese off my pants and he
was like, oh yeah, babe. I got
it and he takes a massive
breath in and then the second
he starts blowing ground beef
just starts spraying and he
lays a strip of the greasiest
chewed up taco meat. Oh. All My
pants. Yes, of course that's
what happens. So, they ended up
costing us like $500 dollars.
Yeah, exactly. I'd say that's
what happen when you go in the
tub, exactly. Uh did you go
crazy when Travis Kelce was on
SNL? I mean, I've been begging
Lauren for two years to have
Travis Kelce host the show
because I had a feeling. I was
like, not only is he the
greatest Titan of all time.
He's funny, he's charming, he's
going to be great and Lauren
was like, yeah, of course, he
can host Heidi, he just has to
win the Super Bowl. Yeah. And I
was like, that's a lot to ask
yeah and then he went and did
it then he went and did it and
I keep saying he won the Super
Bowl and then he won SNL
because he killed it oh he did
crush it yes if it wasn't for
you and your dad what would we
do with all these other
people's careers we're winning
Oscars Super Bowls these are
the guardians do you like
having celebrities sorry guys
celebrities athletes host as
opposed to just celebs I do
because I'm a huge sports fan
and I feel like just the stakes
are a little bit lower because
no one's expecting like an
athletes who be great they're
already great at the thing they
do so when they when they are
great it's like everyone saying
like you read the reviews of
the Kelsey show and it's like
he's the greatest actor of all
time he's better than half the
cast I'm like yeah Wow. Wow.
Yeah. No. No. That one that's
not the truth but he was
amazing by the way. Yeah. Uh he
that was a phenomenal show. It
was so fun. Uh I will say my
favorite sketch you did this
season was the Joker sketch.
Yeah. It was so funny and your
delivery by the way was
phenomenal. It was perfect. I
was like, oh my gosh. Heidi
Gardner for the win on that
one. That was. Joker, don't
dress like the Joker at my
wedding. That was an Andrew
Dismute sketch. He always puts
me in stuff and I'm so lucky.
No. So great. No, he's so lucky
to have you to be to put in a
sketch. Uh Heidi, you're
phenomenal on the show.
Congrats on everything. Best
year dad. Thanks for being on
the show. I appreciate it.
Heidi Gardner Saturday Live
returns April 1st with host
Quinta Brunson musical guest
Lil Yachty. We'll be right back
with Michaela Shepherd. Stick
around everybody.